live from martha's vineyard fox news
investigative reporter and contributor
sarah carter uh did they welcome you
uh i don't know if you have a fox news
mic flag
on your microphone if you did that might
be trouble it might throw you out
you know what you know what shawn you
know what shawn it's all okay they did
welcome me um i i was honest i said i'm
with fox news and i had there was a
variety of opinions look all is quiet
right now here on main street in
martha's vineyard as you call it but we
had a chance today to talk to some
people who had a difference of opinion
than the ones we mainly see and these
were two long time residents here of
martha's vineyard that are angry at the
hypocrisy of some of their neighbors and
want to speak out and they say they
support governor ron desantis take a
listen
were you surprised at all when governor
ron desantis decided okay you know what
guess what i'm going to send
50
of the migrants
who volunteered to come to this to come
to come to boston to come to martha's
vineyard were you surprised when they
arrived
no i wasn't and i actually i really
praise him for doing that because it
wasn't a stunt i know the media has been
saying it this time but um you know how
do you get the attention of of of the
administration how do you get the
attention of harris who's supposed to be
in charge of this
that do you think she's been a good
border czar
it's really a joke and everyone knows it
i think what he did was a a a great
uh
a great um
to you know for the country a great
statement for the country to get the
conversation out there tell the truth
i don't believe anything that comes out
of the administration anymore my message
would be how do you think the people in
texas feel that are getting thousands of
them coming in a day
and uh
we had a little taste of it with 50.
sean whether they agreed with governor
ron desantis or whether they disagreed
with governor ron desantis everybody
that i spoke with here today and i spoke
to quite a few people here today said
there is one thing that is certain is
that the border and immigration is a
huge problem it needs to be addressed it
needs to be resolved and nobody was
happy with what the biden administration
is doing sean all right sarah thanks for
that report from martha's vineyard we
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else